what's going on guys this is rob and we
are making a video where i'm going to
make you an expert on jane foster
thornton that's one of the things that i
want to focus on here right jane foster
has been around for a long long time
technically speaking jane foster first
appeared in journey into mystery number
84 in 1962 and she was created by
stanley and jack kirby but for the
purpose of this video we're only going
to be focusing on her time as the mighty
thor so think of it as a character
explanation isolated to a certain
particular point in a character's
history now there is also the entire
story arc that we covered you can watch
it two ways you can simply watch just
the mighty thor coverage that we had
which focuses exclusively on jane foster
as thor or you can watch the entire
video series that we have which covers
jason aaron's entire run and the mighty
thor with jane foster was simply just a
part of that but there was an interview
that jason aaron had done about seven
years ago where he addressed everything
going on with jane foster when she had
initially popped up and all the things
that went along with it and one of the
things to know is that when jane foster
first emerged as thor in marvel comics
one we didn't know who it was and that's
a significant thing as jason aaron
talked about that in saying that there
were two aspects of this plan that were
at work at the same time the first is
that jane foster becoming thor had roots
that went all the way back to the events
of thor god of thunder and the second is
that he had always planned for this to
be the case so looking at the first one
the idea behind jason aaron doing this
is that with thor god of thunder that
was the first arc that's when he
initially took up riding a thor and blew
the doors off the comics i mean you talk
to anybody out there that's been reading
thor for any measure of time and they'll
tell you thor god of thunder is one of
the best runs on thor there ever was and
the god butcher story arc the very first
arc of that story was phenomenal i still
say to this day jason aaron's entire run
jane foster included is one of the
absolute best thor runs that's ever been
written and probably the best thor run
that's ever been written but when this
all happened the main focus of his
initial run focusing on thor himself was
the idea of worthiness it was whether or
not he was actually worthy to lift his
own hammer and that's why if you go back
and you look at all those things in god
of thunder the emergence of gore the god
butcher the idea that god ignored mortal
beings the entire basis behind why gore
is who he is in the first place it was
thor asking the question am i really
even doing good for mortal people right
like am i really am i benefiting them by
simply just fighting on their behalf or
should i actually be listening to them
when they pray and things along those
lines that was gore's whole stance the
fact that he was he became the person he
was because he lost his whole family he
realized god's existed but god's never
answered their prayers and that as a
result of that gods don't care about
mortals and so over the course of the
entirety of thor god of thunder by the
time you got to the end of that story
specifically going into original sin
thor lost the ability to lift his own
hammer now the events of god butcher at
least the initial arc had long since
passed gore did eventually come back but
that initial arc had long since
concluded but during original sin thor
was basically told by nick fury that
gore was right and that's why you kind
of have to look at the story in its
entirety to understand the significance
of that moment because thor had
continually been questioning his
worthiness ever since he had encountered
gore and learned to understand why gore
became the person that he was and so
when nick fury told him gore was right
you as gods really don't care about
mortals that was kind of the emotional
tipping point and that pushed thor over
the edge he lost the ability to lift
mjolnir and ultimately ended up taking
up the battle ax yarnbjorn instead this
left mjolnir on the surface of the moon
and somebody mysterious had reached down
to pick up the hammer now again we
didn't know who this was in the
beginning instead it was just a new thor
and that was of a huge level of intrigue
for comic book fans a lot of people
really wanted to know who this person
was that was a huge source of mystery
however at the time that this happened
when it was revealed it was a woman who
had done it you ended up seeing a lot of
controversy and the kind of community
when i say controversy that's not the
right word to use it was a ruffling of
feathers right it was those soft gentle
feathers of soft gentle people being
ruffled uh and so the result of this is
you saw people who were just kind of
pissed off that a woman had become thor
or on the other side of the equation
people were mad because they felt that
thor was not really a title so much as a
name now the benefit of comics is it's
whatever you want it to be right that's
the beauty of it all i mean a lot of
people said well no thor is an actual
name it's an actual person in the real
world but marvel comics violates the
idea of how things function in the real
world all the time nobody ever complains
about that so it's just selective
outrage right just choosing what they
wanted to be angry about but the thing
about this is that what you saw right
off the bat were things just happening
quickly when it came to jane foster and
the reason why that matters is because
at the time she was kind of a background
character there was nothing to indicate
that it was it was basically the same
person that version of thor that it
popped up had blonde hair jane foster
had brown hair so there was no reason to
believe that it was a situation where
jane foster had lift the hammer of thor
now there was a lot of rumor and a lot
of speculation a lot of people who were
curious about it and a lot of people
correctly guessed it right a lot of
people guessed it accurately and saying
like it's jane foster it makes the most
sense other people had sources on the
inside
right editors or other writers who
worked at marvel that jason aaron had
talked to or who were going over the
comic to make sure that it was it was
edited correctly for marvel publishing
and they were like i mean just so you
know it's jane foster right so that's
how the industry works there's no
secrets in the world anymore
if you don't know somebody else does
right it's only a matter of time before
they tell you but the thing about this
is that jane foster had actually been a
part of the congress of worlds which was
basically quite literally a congress
that represented the different realms of
the asgardian mythos right the nine
realms midgard or earth was one of those
and jane foster was the representative
of midgard on the congress of worlds now
another major focal point of her
character at the time was that she had
been diagnosed with breast cancer and so
essentially it was like jason aaron was
just writing her out right it was only a
matter of time before she died we didn't
really have a lot of precedent to
indicate that the only one we did have
was the death of captain marvel in 1984
by jim starlin and so cancer in marvel
comics it does exist but it really seems
to present itself as one of these things
where unless you're someone like wade
wilson with an insane healing factor uh
cancer will ultimately kill you it's
kind of like this immutable
indestructible thing that nobody can
stop and i think that's just marvel's
way of highlighting the significance of
that illness and then applying it to
comics to show just how terrible of an
illness it is but again all these
different things that were going on with
jane foster at this point in time none
of them indicated that it was jane
foster who was thor and in fact all
these clues indicated that it wasn't her
right how could a person with cancer
lift the hammer of mjolnir which i guess
is possible but then go on to become
thor at the same time she was basically
dying she was undergoing chemotherapy
she was incredibly weak none of it
really seemed to make any sense but
focusing on the publishing side and in
fact one of the questions that a lot of
people have is why is jane foster
referred to as the mighty thor so that
is as much a publishing initiative as it
is a name in the comic and the reason
why is because at the time
while odin's son had lost the ability to
lift his hammer his story was still
being wrapped up in his own thor comic
and so it wouldn't make any sense for
marvel to come along and publish two
comics called thor it just doesn't do
that even with spider-man when you had
like five different spider-man comics
going at the same time you only had one
amazing spider-man comic then you had
things like sensational spider-man the
web of spider-man friendly neighborhood
spider-man so on and so forth but they
all weren't called amazing spider-man
because it would have been very very
difficult to keep track of all the
comics themselves and so as a result of
that when jane foster initially popped
up since thor volume 3 which had started
with j michael strozinski back in 2006
was still going on what you got was
simply the mighty thor comic and so when
the thor odenson comic when thor vol 3
concluded then jane foster's the mighty
thor was renamed to thor vol 4. and then
by that point odin's son was just kind
of shuffled off to avengers and new
avengers and the reason for that is
because at that point in time marvel was
really really close to basically
launching seeker wars and for those of
you guys who aren't familiar with that
secret wars was of course the grand
reshuffling of marvel comics basically
killing the multiverse so on and so
forth and while marvel didn't
necessarily build it that way the
evidence indicated marvel was going to
reboot but it seemed as though they got
cold feet at the last minute and
ultimately didn't but the reason why
this is important is because odin's son
was part of the avengers and new
avengers multiversal avengers team and
so his stories continued on the main
thor comics simply focused on jane
foster now for her part she was part of
that to a degree but because you already
had one thor dealing with the
multiversal collapse jason aaron wanted
to focus on the stories of jane foster
and so leading into the events of secret
wars for that period of time the
beginning of thor volume 4 really
running from issues one through eight it
dealt with a few things here and there
but that was largely building up to the
post-secret wars landscape the big story
that jason aaron wanted to tell with
jane foster so you did see a few things
that were going on with like dario agar
the leader of roxanne corporation you
saw the rise of malakith the accursed
who had made an alliance with the frost
giants which would go on to become part
of the war of realm story we'll talk
about that here in a minute but almost
immediately after jane foster was
introduced you basically got secret wars
now that's where the main focus of jane
foster at least the thor mythos began to
shift away from odinson himself and
focus on jane and the reason why i say
that is that with the tail end of
avengers and new avengers basically
coming to a close and with the launch of
secret wars issue number zero it was the
last two universes in the multiverse
crashing into each other you had the
main marvel universe then you had the
ultimate universe and so what you got
was reed richards and black panther and
spider-man peter parker miles morales
and a few others including jane foster
aboard a multiversal raft that would
basically survive the collapse of the
multiverse and so when you got into
secret wars and you essentially saw the
creation or at least the formation of
battle world by dr doom who would absorb
the powers of the beyonders jane foster
was among the heroes that had survived
the multi-russell collapse and woke up
on this world or at least stepped out
into this world from that raft and so
what you saw following that point was
basically the stories of the characters
branching out in their own themes jane
foster found herself part of the thor
corps which was basically the police
force of god king doom on battle world
but realizing that this new battle world
was essentially the result of a
combination of what was left of the
multiverse merged into a singular
location that the memories of everybody
on this entirety of battle world outside
of those who survived the raft had just
been modified over time by doctor doom
to where they didn't remember what their
universe was supposed to have been as
far as they were aware things had always
been this way and so she found herself
as part of the thor core regarding the
entirety of the secret wars event at the
event's conclusion facing off against a
whole host of villains and different
things along those lines but what this
meant is that when secret wars concluded
that the stories of jane foster as thor
effectively just picked right back up
where they had left off at the end of
thor volume 4 going into secret wars now
marvel did do your standard fare as part
of all new all different marvel and jane
foster they put her on the avengers and
they showed people hey like this is a
new character and that kind of a thing
but focusing on her own thor comics the
truth about this is that jason aaron was
establishing an underlying current an
underlying story and there were actually
a few of them so the first one is that
where there were some feathers that were
ruffled over the result of jane foster
becoming thor that that was written into
the book right where people in the real
world were like no jane foster is not
thor odin's sons thor and i won't hear
otherwise that in the comic itself
people like odin and other asgardians
refused to accept jane foster as thor
and it was something that she routinely
ran across right no matter what it was
that she did at the end of the day they
would never see her as a thor now she
had of course revealed her identity to
odin's son at a point in time and in
fact odin's son had given her the
blessing to go forward as thor so even
with the blessing of odin's son nobody
else would really accept it i mean there
were a few here and there right there
were some asgardians who were like i
mean she's doing good stuff cut her some
slack but a lot of the asgardians who
were really be holding more to tradition
and simply couldn't accept change just
never really wanted to accept her as a
thor so again in a lot of ways that
mirrored the real world another major
caveat for her character was her cancer
and that was the big question that a lot
of people have if jane foster has breast
cancer and she's basically dying or at
least undergoing chemotherapy how does
that affect her as thor and this was
jason aaron's point right off the bat as
soon as he had reintroduced her or
brought her in and introduced the idea
of breast cancer one of the first things
he established is that whenever she
changes into thor it basically purges
her body of chemotherapy thereby setting
her back to zero so in effect her body's
ability to heal from cancer from chemo
ends up getting eradicated every time
she turns into thor but her cancer
remains and so he'd essentially put a
clock on her it's only a matter of time
before jane foster dies now the reality
here is it was really jason aaron taking
what is in effect the overarching
concept of changing characters in comics
and applying it to the comic you talk to
anybody who's read comics for any
measure of time and they'll always tell
you everything goes back to normal for
the most part right i mean characters
change names change things like that it
all goes back right it always goes back
to the status quo which is why i never
understood why people got so upset about
jane foster being thor in the first
place it was never going to last forever
but the other thing that was going on is
as far as the larger story arcs were
concerned that jason aaron was building
up to something called the war of realms
and the war of realms was this just
great story it was a phenomenal story it
largely centered around malakith the
accursed and so what you had was really
jane foster playing double duty that on
one side of the equation she was
fighting alongside the earth's
superheroes the avengers people like
that against various threats and then on
the other side you had malikith the
curse who was traveling around the
different realms the various realms
conquering them subjugating them and
then crea you know expanding his own
army and just going after realm after
realm after round so it was this great
big huge conflict that was out there
there were some stories that jane foster
had where she was never really a main
focus a lot of those were crossovers so
you're looking at things like pleasant
hill you're looking at things like
secret empire all of which were great
stories in their own right i mean don't
get me wrong they were phenomenal
stories but the question of whether or
not jane foster would ever actually end
up staying thor for any real measure of
time was definitively answered by jason
aaron in a story called the death of the
mighty thor now as the name suggests
this was the final story arc of jane
foster as thor it was not the death of
jane foster it was really more just
wrapping up the arc of her being thor
and this focused largely on the man gog
and this was a very very particular and
really an important story here because
really looking beyond the publishing
side and focusing more on the character
of jane over the course of her time as
thor again she had constantly been
trying to prove herself to the
asgardians that she was as much of a
thor as odin's son was but almost every
step of the way they had rejected her
but what this did is it led to the
arrival of the man gog and instead of
simply just fleeing which was the
expectation that odin and the other
asgardians would have of her she stood
fast and went toe-to-toe against the
man-gog now this was a monumental feat
and earned jane foster the respect of
virtually every asgardian and the reason
for that is because for those of you
guys who don't know the man gog is
basically an indestructible being right
the man gog is just this just pure force
of hatred that somewhere along the line
odin had basically been a dick to a
world
essentially led to their destruction but
in doing so the the hatred of that
entire race culminated in a singular
being the man gog has been around
publishing wise in marvel comics for
decades and every time this guy shows up
pardon my language here odin shuts his
pants to be quite frank with you guys
that's usually what happens right the
man gog is just a ridiculously powerful
force of energy and is almost completely
and totally impossible to kill the best
you can do is hold him off or imprison
him which is usually always the response
of odin whenever the man god shows up
with jane foster it was the same way why
jason aaron didn't write some kind of
mary sue story where against all odds
she pulled some level of power that
odin's never had and destroyed the man
god instead what ended up happening is
she had basically grabbed mjolnir and
then threw the man gog into the sun and
because of that you basically had jane
foster who had previously been told if
she were to turn into uh into thor again
it could potentially kill her at least
she was told that by doctor strange what
she did is she turned into thor one last
time defeated the man god and then
relented and so in effect it looked like
jane foster was going to die now this
all took place again post all new all
different marvel going into uh marvel
legacy and and the reason why that
matters is for you guys who don't know
marvel legacy was just a numbering
initiative so say for example that with
thor vol 5 issue number one that's
actually thor issue number 701 marvel
legacy was just doing that it was just
renumbering the comics it was entirely
ceremonial it served no real purpose
whatsoever except to confuse people but
that's why if you go and you read jane
foster thor you'll see things like thor
issue number 704 which is actually where
this story took place but that's why
you'll see that it's because it's just
legacy numbering is all it is but the
point behind this story is that it was
jane foster losing the mantle of thor
that realizing if she kept going she
would succumb to her cancer what ended
up happening is it was believed that she
had died and so thor had tried to
resurrect jane foster and with the help
of odin's son was basically able to pull
it off and when i say resurrect i mean
it actually happened jane foster was
dead and her spirit was at the halls of
all holland and she was gonna go in and
that was gonna be the end of her but
they ended up bringing her back and she
chose to come back as well but she
devoted all of her time to her
chemotherapy and then convinced thor to
take his hammer and his title back and
that's how you ended up getting odin's
son going back to becoming the thor that
we all knew and that we all basically
love but for the most part that's the
story of jane foster as thor now there
is a little bit more that goes on there
right she ended up becoming a valkyrie
later on down the line but that's really
how all that works right that idea of
jane foster thor again it's really more
explaining a story arc as opposed to
doing a traditional character
explanation where we run over like their
entire publication history in a more
condensed way but that's effectively
what took place but if that sounds cool
to you like i said i have the entire
jason aaron run you're welcome to check
it out the jane foster mighty thor run
is cool but it also fits a lot better if
you focus on the entirety of the jason
aaron run from thor god of thunder
running all the way up until what was it
it wasn't the war thor storyline it was
uh the final one where you had like god
thor where thor basically became god
gore came back he became a universe like
all that kind of crazy stuff i know it
sounds nuts believe me it's awesome it's
a lot cooler than it may sound
gore does become a whole universe it's
pretty wild but again that's basically
the gist of the character so with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end thank you guys for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace